uh let me correct that no they don't
need faith in Christ to be baptized what
she's confusing like I
confused I confus and she's confusing is
that when the gospel gospel writers or
when the evangelists are preaching
they're preaching to grown-ups right
yeah so when we read passages that are
directed to grown-ups you're obviously
going to tell grown-ups or Jews or
Greeks repent believe and be baptized
obviously
they are mature individuals who can
discern and understand the message so
you you're a Jew you need to believe in
Jesus Christ do you believe in Jesus
Christ get baptized all right you
Greek you believe in Jesus Christ that
he's the son of God yes okay get
baptized so what she's confusing like I
confuse because I was taught Baptist
theology that because the statements
regarding baptism are focused on
individual
that are hearing the message Apostles
are preaching to people who can discern
the message and make the choice that
means only those who can discern believe
and repent are to be baptized nowhere in
the Bible does it say only those who
believe and repent should be baptized
yeah it says believe and repent and
you'll be baptized but it doesn't say
only someone who believes and repents
should be baptized it doesn't address
the issue of what about infants now take
it next step our are we to seriously
assume that when a household hears the
gospel a household hears the gospel that
only those who can discern the gospel
and make a profession of faith will be
baptized but the infants will be set
aside households are baptized here on
acts
23747 specifically Acts 2 if you read 41
it says 3,000 were baptized on that day
3,000 now when they went to Pentecost
that only
adult males go or do they went with
their family yeah they went with their
family so then when let's say these
adults get saved and they go get
baptized you're telling me that the text
then will imply that their children who
are too young were were set aside no no
no don't get baptized them only you that
doesn't function in that part of the
world and Old Testament mindset when the
head of the household does something the
whole house household is involved in
that act in the Old Testament the
principle is if you are an Israelite and
a head of the household and you have
male Sons they are to get circumcised on
the E day right yes but they don't know
any better they don't have a choice to
follow the god of Israel it was assumed
that if you're born in an Israelite
house household if so facto you belong
to the Covenant Community and therefore
you have to get circumcised in order to
be incorporated in Covenant Life or you
be cut off wow
unless we have explicit reference from
the New Testament that this principle
which is found all throughout the Old
Testament has now been changed and
overridden the assumption is that when
you have head of households going
forward to get saved that everyone of
that household will follow the decision
of the head of the household and will be
then fully Incorporated in that
inclusion within the church well you
can't be part of the church if you're
not baptized the Bible talks about
households now what I used to try to
argue because I was a Baptist well
nowhere in those passages are we shown
that those households consisted of
children well that's an argument from
Silence here I'll show you household
baptisms where it says Lydia and her
household they say well Lydia's
household doesn't necessarily include
infants or children well okay I agree
but that's not the point the principle
is that when the head of the house gets
baptized the whole house household gets
baptized whether their children or Not
Here acts 16 14-
15 and when a woman named Lydia from the
city of thyra a seller of purple Fabrics
a worship God was listening whose heart
the Lord opened to pay attention to
things spoken by by Paul when she and
her household had been baptized this is
the principle so she beli and her and
her household got baptized now
irrespective of whether they're children
or not the principle is whole households
got baptized when the head of the house
house went ahead for baptism so that
means if a whole household follows the
lead of the head unless you can prove to
me that there was no house household
that included infants and if infants
were part of the household they refused
baptism this is really desperate this is
why from early on you'll find the
widespread practice among Christians is
they baptize even infants now you will
find statements from tertulia who a
Church writer not a Church Father you'll
find statements where he said that there
were households that would defer the
baptism of infants until they were
little mature do you know why here let
me give you another example of
households getting baptized acts 188 and
chrispus the leader of the synagogue
believe the Lord with all his household
and many of the Corinthians when they
heard were believing and being baptized
or acts
16 30 to 34 watch here now when it says
the whole house will rejoice that
doesn't every single person just means
collectively right those who could
Rejoice rejoiced those who could
understand Rejoice but it doesn't mean
that those in the household were all
mature enough that they could rejoice
and respond it simply means the
household Rejoice so if you had children
who were too young that doesn't exclude
them you understand the principle I say
man my buddy Pat's household had a party
and they were celebrating and everyone
celebrated now does that mean you don't
have infants in the
household no that's that's the point but
now coming back to tertullian what was
Tan's Point tulan said that you know why
they would defer baptism for infants do
you know why I I don't know why he would
say it because they believe water
baptism removed sin but infants were
born in a state of Innocence they had no
sense to remove so now why not wait
until they sin so that baptism can them
purify them of their sin but Baptists
don't believe that do they no so now
notice the logic of the church the early
church said hey wait wait since water
baptism removes sin water baptism brings
about cleansing of sin that's what they
all believe there is not a single Church
writer even Heretics affirm this not a
single Church writer that said water
baptism
doesn't result in forgiveness of sin
they believe in water baptism the Holy
Spirit came upon you made you alive
United to Christ and if you had any sins
you'd be forgiven they all believe water
baptism was used to bring forgiveness
sins so then they started thinking to
themselves hold on well our infants have
been sin so if they haven't sinned why
baptize them they're already innocent as
it is let's wait for them to end up
actually sinning so that they can
baptize and all those sins will be
forgiven but by that logic then why not
just wait till they die on their death
bed to baptize in fact you know who did
that you know who actually deferred his
baptism on his death bed I have no clue
Constantine Constantine when he made
Christianity legal deliberately chose
not to get baptized in water until his
death bed and he had an Aryan named Yus
of n
nikomia baptized him before he died
because he believed then all of the sins
he came up at that point would be
cleansed it's like he was trying to find
a loophole yes so now if we were to that
logic well hold on let's wait till our
children sin then why not just wait till
their death bed that's kind of silly
logic isn't it yeah that's that's dumb
but what's the point tertullian's
comment shows two things they all
believe water baptism was used by God to
forgive you of your sins Baptists don't
believe that but this was the universal
teaching of the church and secondly they
believe that though humans are born of
sinful parents so that a baby will
inherit a sinful proclivity
that child is not condemned for the sin
of their parents or the sin of Adam and
Eve they are born in the state of
innocence in the State of Grace but with
a sinful
proclivity so that's why they thought
well let's just wait for them to sin so
then why then baptizing in if water
baptism removes sin well because that
act of water baptism is what unites you
to Christ and makes you one with him in
the spirit and part of the spiritual
body so so though a child is in a state
of Innocence that child is not
necessarily a member of the body of
Christ until he or she is baptized and
act 16334 is another one for you and
after he brought them out he said sir
what must I do be saved they believe in
the Lord Jesus and you'll be saved you
your household now notice when he
believes his whole household will be
saved they're included when I was a
calvinist and a Reformed Baptist I had a
hard time with this passage and would
come up with every explanation to
explain this away when the leader of the
household believes then God will grant
salvation even to the children until
they reach an age of accountability and
then they'll be responsible for their
own faith or lack thereof